we have a really serious situation of
authoritarianism that ties into
suppression of speech actual suppression
of speech
it possibly ties into the plan to steal
this election in november by donald
trump and what's happening is that
paramilitary
federal law enforcement officers have
been dispatched to portland oregon
they're grabbing people including
protesters not just looters
they're taking them away in unmarked
vehicles they don't have badges
and this has been confirmed by the
department of homeland security this is
really actually
serious these paramilitaries are driving
around
in unmarked cars wearing camouflage
really more appropriate for the desert
than downtown portland oregon
protesters are being detained even in
the absence of evidence that any crime
was committed and this is an
authoritarian
type show of force the claim from the
department of homeland security is that
these troops which really is what they
are
are being sent to portland to keep the
peace and to protect federal property
the stories we're hearing are that
people are being grabbed
thrown in unmarked vans taken to
undisclosed locations not being accused
of any crime in many cases some are and
in most cases
they are being released some are charged
with crimes
some of the people being detained are
not even near
federal property which is supposedly the
reason these federal troops are there
in the first place and many aren't being
told why
they are being detained they are just
protesters protected
by the first amendment the mayor of
portland ted wheeler says he didn't ask
for help
he has asked the federal troops to leave
and yet there they are
so that's story number one what is
actually happening
on the ground and we're still getting
more information about what's happening
there
the second story is that this is
potentially a test
of what may happen in many cities
starting as soon as this week to repress
protests charlie pierce has a good piece
about this in esquire
where he points out when trump tries
something and gets away with it he does
more of it
and pierce is suggesting maybe this is a
dry run
for what trump was threatening at the
start of the george floyd protests a
couple of months ago
major deployments of militarized law
enforcement
or even straight-up military to urban
areas
so there's two sub-stories to that
second story
number one is the authoritarianism
spreading to repress protests the second
part is actually
trying to cause confrontations the
troops that is
in order to benefit trump politically by
pointing to violent protesters
which they will induce to violence we've
already seen reports
that the protester protests themselves
are seeing more unrest in portland since
the deployment of the troops so there's
the authoritarianism
but there's also the deployment of
troops to create
unrest to then point to look at all
these violent people
we need a bigger show of force which
gets us to the third piece of
this which is these authoritarian forces
being sent into cities now could be a
trial balloon
for sending or keeping them in cities in
november
for the purpose of intimidating around
the election
and that would be like the closure of
the loop in terms of what's going on
that strategy requires some foresight
which trump does not seem able to do
but william barr certainly would be
capable of that and some of the others
involved may well be
now in terms of legality of course
trump's justice department and dhs
say this is legal the aclu and other
lawyers have said
you know th this this could arguably be
kidnapping and abduction right i mean
you've got paramilitaries without badges
and camo
in unmarked cars grabbing people taking
them away
often not telling them what crime
they're suspected of committing and
eventually releasing them without having
charged them of any crime it is going in
the direction of a secret police
sort of thing now to take a brief detour
this is important
as an opportunity to prepare you for
some bad arguments from the right about
this
right-wing darling ben shapiro tweeted
in response to some of what we're seeing
in portland quote
fascism is not federal law enforcement
and forcing the law against rioters and
looters
and they are arresting rioters and
looters in portland not mere protesters
fascism is the chinese government
shuttling uyghurs by train to
concentration camps
well he's right that that certainly uh
is fascistic
what's going on in china and everybody
should be calling it out
and and most people are um but
there's a petri dish of nonsense here
it's almost like a one-sentence gish
gallop because a lot of stuff is being
mixed up
it is true that law enforcement
arresting criminals is not fascism that
that that's completely true
that's not actually what's at issue here
what we have here are
countless videos of mere protesters
being brutally repressed
who have not looted who have not rioted
we have
law enforcement in unmarked cars popping
out in a city
in camo that does not match the urban
setting in which they're operating
wearing desert camo without badges that
is deliberate intimidation
that's starting to border on some of the
stuff you see in authoritarian and
totalitarian states and to top it off
there are reports coming in of people
being taken off to undisclosed locations
not being given due process just being
held and ultimately released
so don't fall for law enforcement doing
law enforcement work
isn't fascism no it's not that's not
what this is about
this is about camouflaged military in
unmarked vehicles
sent in to repress protests possibly
as a trial balloon for intimidation to
happen nationally as we approach
election day we almost have a situation
where portland portland police officers
should be protecting protesters
from the guys with no badges in the
unmarked vans
that's how crazy it is don't we have a
right to know who is policing us
aren't combatants as insane as that word
is
required to indicate who they are and
who they work for
anonymous police in camo with no badges
is what's going on right now this could
just as easily be some right wing
militia
as it could be a prison riot squad being
repurposed and in fact
how long will it be until some
right-wing militia that looks just like
these guys
kidnaps and kills someone and it gets
swept under the rug
the city should file a lawsuit and put
it in the hands of the courts
i'd be lying if i said i knew how the
courts would rule
on what's going on this is still
developing we will have more
upcoming if you are anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video
chat this is not a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary
care and it's also so much more
affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video